generally speaking good rule-of-thumb
sequels are not as good as the originals
generally speaking
Kung Fu Panda 2 so Kung Fu Panda 1 was
the story of a panda played by Jack
Black who is the chosen one and learns
kung foo and it was a good movie it was
enjoyable to naturally sequel time and
how does this equal stack up Kung Fu
Panda 2 does exactly what a sequel
should do first of all we'll take PO the
Panda so in the first one he learns kung
fu and he saves the day so naturally he
knows kung fu now usually that's a
problem for sequels so what they'll do
is they'll nerf him they'll make him a
bumbling idiot again who doesn't know
kung fu like it wasn't the first one not
Kung Fu Panda 2 in Kung Fu Panda 2 po is
it badass
oh yeah he's still bumbling and lovable
but he throws down when he needs to dude
knows kung fu he's kind of like
Michelangelo from the Ninja Turtles he's
funny he's not the most coordinated
turtle but still knows his martial arts
and he throws down so I liked how they
kept everything he learned from the
first one and they moved forward with it
not back and so now we have the villain
a peacock voiced by Gary Oldman who
threatens all of kung foo and this guy
has some big shoes to fill because ian
mcshane was the bad guy in the first one
and he was bad at he's ian mcshane as
you've probably found out by now I like
ian mcshane playing villains that being
said I've also seen the professional and
the fifth element Gary Oldman's an
awesome villain as well and he is great
as the villainous peacock who threatens
all of kung foo what I liked about his
character is his character was actually
a lot different than ian mcshane from
the first one it's really easy to
cookie-cutter villains in movies
nowadays so I really liked him as a
villain I personally think the villain
in Kung Fu Panda 2 stands up in terms of
status of villain and the likes of
Skarin Jafar yeah he was awesome and the
story in Kung Fu Panda 2 is great they
go deeper into the story of Po
everything you look for in a sequel is
in Kung Fu Panda 2 not to mention it's a
CGI movie so the 3d looks awesome and
the cinematography and Kung Fu was every
bit as awesome as you'd expect in a
summer movie and I'm not gonna lie to
you in the end of the movie when
everything's just going down it's all
coming to a head you just sit back and
you're like this movie is awesome and it
was funny to have some really good humor
in it I really can't find much bad in
Kung Fu Panda 2 when you have a movie
with a cool character in a cool villain
that delves into the main hero at a
personal level has some sweet emotion
because the movie does have some good
emotion in it as I say the movie had
heart and it did it well and the movie
has awesome kung fu' and
what's not to like it's one of those I
wouldn't call it a kids movie it's a
family movie for sure but if you're an
adult and you go see Kung Fu Panda 2
there is no way you're going to walk out
of that movie and go I didn't have a
good time you may think you have to say
that but you're not going to feel that
so just be honest with yourself and say
you liked Kung Fu Panda 2 Kung Fu Panda
2 is one of those rare situations for
the sequel is better than the first
movie I enjoy the first couple Shrek
movies but I now enjoy the Kung Fu Panda
movies more so do yourself a favor this
weekend go check it out go see it
because Kung Fu Panda 2 is awesome
tacular I was really debating as to
whether or not Kung Fu Panda 2 was buy
it on blu-ray or awesome tacular but I
got to say it hit all the right notes
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more because there's always
more